Hey youtubers it's Charlie and some unfinished
Avengers 2 footage was just screened in London
so I wanted to do a bonus video explaining
what that was and what they're going to be
doing at comic con and some of the changes
to The Vision character.
Them changing characters is a totally normal
thing.
Thor is going through some big changes so
it's just another day in the Marvel Universe.
Hello any new people, if you're just finding
me I do Marvel videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'll even be recording the Marvel Panel at
Comic Con.
It's going to be big.
So I'll just start with the footage they screened
and then explain the Vision.
It was all unfinished scenes from the movie,
no special effects, just raw capture that
had been edited down.
They showed of The Hulkbuster Armor, way bigger
than the Igor suit we saw in Iron Man 3.
It's the customary red and gold colors.
Size wise it's about the same size as the
hulk.
In the comics it always seemed way bigger
than Hulk.
But Mark Ruffalo's version of the Hulk was
also shrunk down from the Ang Lee version
and the Ed Norton version.
So it makes sense they wouldn't go too crazy
with the Hulkbuster.
There was a bunch of Scarlet Witch Quicksilver
stuff.
They were seen inside these clear Perspex
Prison cells, then fighting alongside Hawkeye,
like in the images we saw from the set earlier
this year.
They were also using their powers, but because
the scenes didn't have special effects, Quicksilver
looked like he was jogging and Scarlet Witch
was floating blocks.
There was a really good look at the new redesigned
Avengers Tower.
It looks a lot like the interior of the SHIELD
Helicarrier.
Bruce Banner and Tony Stark each have twin
labs next to each other to make all of the
science, there's a hanger bay for the Quintjet
which will be in the movie and all of the
Avengers have sleeping quarters.
I'm assuming that while everyone but Thor
has a home somewhere else, they'll be bunking
in the Tower during the events of the movie.
Although it's been explained that Thor has
been living on earth since the events of Dark
World.
Presumably the movie will explain why.
That doesn't sound like a ton of footage and
everyone is expecting the Comic Con trailer
they're bringing to be an order of magnitude
cooler.
With finished special effects.
It won't be a full on trailer, more of an
extended promo reel.
I'll be doing a full breakdown of that and
uploading panel footage.
That's happening Saturday night July 26th.
I probably won't be able to upload it till
super late that night, but I'll be tweeting
the shit out of the panel while it's happening.
There are a few movies Marvel is not taking
to comic con like Guardians of The Galaxy,
but aside from Avengers 2, the cast of Ant
Man will be there and Marvel will reveal the
complete slate of Phase 3 films.
So now let's talk about The Vision.
Just like with Ultron, they're changing his
backstory to fit within the Movie Canon they've
created.
Here's a quick history of him in the comics.
The Vision was created by Ultron using the
remains of the Original Human Torch android.
I know everyone thinks of Johnny Storm as
the Human Torch, but before him, an android
named Jim Hammond used the mantle during world
war 2 to fight Hitler and the Axis powers.
That version of the character is actually
one of Marvel's very first superheroes.
Ultron reprogrammed the android to fight the
Avengers, that first happened in the late
60s.
Ultron programmed Vision with the neural patterns
of Wonder Man so that he could infiltrate
the Avengers.
Ultron also embedded a failsafe device called
a control crystal in him.
Like an override switch.
He got his name "Vision" when the Janet Van
Dyne Wasp saw him for the first time when
Ultron trapped them revealing Visions true
form.
Wasp called him an "unearthly, inhuman Vision".
So already you can see some changes will be
made to the origin story in the movies because
we have no Wasp on the team yet.
Vision ended up sympathizing with the Avengers
and helped them defeat Ultron.
I feel like some of the details of the character
everyone knows, like he ended up getting married
to Scarlet Witch.
Eventually that failsafe device Ultron embedded
in him malfunctioned and he went nuts trying
to make the world perfect.
He fixed the problem, but the military deemed
him a huge security threat.
When Scarlet Witch lost her mind and set off
the whole no more mutants house of M storyline,
the Vision was torn to pieces and stuck in
storage.
Eventually they brought him back for Mighty
Avengers and most recently he's been a big
part of Marvel's AI storyline.
If you remember, Mighty Avengers is rumored
to be the inspiration for the story in Avengers
2.
So you should all re-read that book.
The interesting thing about his character
is that he is an android, but he develops
very human connections to people, He even
had romantic relationships with Scarlet Witch
and later with Cassandra Lang, she's the daughter
of the Scott Lang Ant Man.
The one Paul Rudd is playing in the Ant Man
movie.
So regardless of what the Avengers 2 movie
does with him.
The core of his character will be this very
human attachment to the Avengers by the end
of the film.
Hopefully he'll still be around in Avengers
3 and maybe show up in a few of the spinoff
movies.
What is the movie going to change about his
character?
Mostly the origin story, the outcome is the
same.
He becomes an Avenger.
That part won't change, but he will be based
on Stark Tech created to fight Ultron.
Instead of created by Ultron to fight the
Avengers.
There's a couple things that have been confirmed
that support this.
Mostly that Paul Bettany has been cast as
the Vision.
Not just his voice either, it will be his
body in the film too, motion capture, just
like Ultron is a combination of suit and motion
capture.
I am curious to see which character they let
name him, whether it's Tony Stark or someone
else.
And if they keep the line from the comic or
do some twist on it.
Speaking of motion capture, did you know that
Andy Serkis has a role in the movie.
A motion capture role that is.
They haven't revealed who, other than to say
it's not Thanos.
But if Paul Bettany is doing Vision and James
Spader is Ultron.
Who could Andy Serkis be?
My thoughts are that he's got a super small
part that will be a character Joss Whedon
will use to tease the next Avengers movie.
Like someone new we didn't know was going
to be in the movie.
When Whedon talked about the first Avengers
movie, he said that when he was just doing
initial talks to join the project before they
ever shot the film.
He said they'd have to let him use Ultron
at some point.
So if he was thinking Ultron before the first
Avengers ever started, I'm really curious
which character he's got in his back pocket
now.
In addition to the super secret part Serkis
is playing, he's also a motion capture consultant
for the movie, so he helps Mark Ruffalo do
a better Hulk and he'll help Paul Bettany
and James Spader with their characters too.
Josh Brolin may do a few days of work on the
movie since Thanos is supposed to have a super
quick cameo again.
They shot all the Thanos stuff in Guardians
before the cast him, but in future films,
they'll probably do motion capture for him
too.
But let me know who you think Andy Serkis
is playing in Avengers 2 and do you care that
they changed Ultron and Vision's backstories?
I'm a huge Whedon fan, so I totally don't
mind whatever he wants to change, I've learned
to just trust him and roll with it.
And I'd be totally cool if Andy Serkis just
played all the motion capture characters.
I wonder what that movie would look like?
So I'm going to do at least one more Marvel
video before comic con, I'm doing a special
Marvel giveaway, so I'll explain how that's
going to work.
I'll try to post it by next Tuesday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I'll be posting a bunch of the panels next
weekend, so even if you can't go you'll still
be able to see some of it.
Right now click here to learn about the new
Female Thor and click here for my review of
the Guardians of The Galaxy IMAX footage
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!